-Nice to see you.
I wanted
to start off the interview
by showing a photo of you.
-Uh-oh.
-This is posted
[ Laughter ]
by Dwyane Wade.
-Oh, Lord.
-Posted a picture of you.
-Oh, my goodness.
[ Laughter ]
-This is a young
Stephen A. Smith. College?
-College at Winston-Salem State.
But you see, this is bad, man,
because this dude, Dwyane Wade,
the dude that walks around
with pink pants on
[ Laughter ]
and the whole stuff.
He's got me because he's
a three-time champion,
a future first-ballot
Hall of Famer.
So, when he says
he would drop 50 on me,
it's not like he's lying.
[ Laughter ]
You know what?
I'd be better than anybody
I've seen on the Knicks lately.
[ Laughter and oohs ]
You know? I mean,
let me tell you something, man.
I'm here today
because "The Tonight Show."
Jimmy Fallon called me
and it's my honor and privilege
[ Faux-tearfully ]
to be here, but,
[ Laughter ]
I'm getting emotional right now.
-It's alright, bud.
I know.
-These dudes, man, these --
Hold.
[ Laughter ]
[ Tender music plays ]
These dudes, man...
-The Knicks.
-...they keep doing this to me.
[ Laughter ]
The other night,
they were up 17 points.
[ Laughter ]
-I know, I know.
And I was on TV,
on "NBA Countdown,"
and I said, "You know what?
It doesn't make any difference.
They're never going to change.
They're just going
to lose the lead."
[ Laughter ]
And, sure enough, they did it.
Sure enough, they did it.
I mean, I'm asking you
to make me out to be a liar
and you couldn't do that right.
[ Laughter ]
[ Sad trombone plays ]
-I do want to discuss
more sports scenes with you,
but first, there's something
that I just loved about you.
-Okay.
-I'm a fan, but,
you are a character
on "General Hospital."
[ Laughter ]
-Yes. Yeah.
-And I did not know this
but I am a giant
"General Hospital" fan
-Are you?
-from back in the day.
Yeah, I'm like old-school.
-Now, you got to remember,
when you say old-school,
what does that mean?
Because me,
I'm talking Luke and Laura.
[ Oohs and applause ]
-Yeah. I'm talking about --
♪ Think of Laura,
laugh, don't cry ♪
♪ I know she'd
want it that way ♪
-That's right. That's right.
That's right.
You talking about Felicia.
That's what you talking about.
-Oh, no, no, no.
Her husband --
-No, I'm talking about Bobbie.
-Bobbie? Z? You talking
about Bobbie Spencer?
-Bobbie Spencer, Jackie Zeman.
-That's right,
Jackie Zeman, Bobbie Spencer.
That was Luke sister
on "General Hospital."
-I went to --
-You know he got --
He almost died because of her.
[ Laughter ]
Did you know that?
-Luke, or Tony Geary?
-He was in -- Luke.
He was in the elevator, okay?
-Yes.
And he was trying to protect her
and got shot.
Almost got shot years ago.
[ Laughter ]
She almost got Luke killed.
-I know.
[ Laughter ]
Bobbie's trouble, man.
-You got the Cassadines,
you got the weather machine.
-No, here's what happened.
The Cassadines,
here's what happened.
I was doing stand-up in L.A.
and I got invited to lunch
at Jackie Zeman's house.
-Wow!
-It was amazing.
Beautiful place.
And I see the
Quartermaines talking.
-Well, that kind of
hurt your feelings, didn't it?
-It did bum me out.
-Because, you know,
you get caught up.
See, you watch a soap opera --
-Yo, this can't happen.
You know, you enemies,
stay enemies!
-That's exactly right!
-You can't be seen
out in public like that.
-Barbecues.
Exactly right! I go,
"I've got to get out."
I got to get myself
out of the situation.
-That's right.
-So I left.
-I'm a surveillance expert
for the mob.
My character's name is Brick
on "General Hospital."
-Brick!
-Sonny Corinthos
is my boss, alright?
[ Applause ]
-That's my dude.
I love Sonny Corinthos.
-We so real with each other
that, even off set,
if I saw you messing with him,
I might have
to try and do something.
-That's what I'm talking about.
[ Applause ]
-Because that's my job.
-That's exactly right.
-That's my job.
-Yeah. I love how
excited you get.
You get me excited,
watching you.
You get excited when you talk,
when you talk and then you talk
about something more
and then you get excited,
then you get louder!
-That's right.
-You always did that?
-Not always.
Well, first of all,
I'm the youngest of six
and I was raised by five women.
-Yeah.
-So let's be clear.
I didn't talk loud too often.
[ Laughter ]
Let's be very, very clear
about that.
My sisters would not hesitate
to abuse me.
Their names are Linda,
[Indistinct],
-Alright, alright, alright.
-Abigail, and Carmen.
[ Laughter and applause ]
Alright?
-You don't have to rat them out.
-Yes, I am ratting them out
because they would beat up
their little brother,
yes, they would.
[ Laughter ]
But the bottom line is
it taught you --
it taught me -- you talk
to ladies a certain way
-That's right.
-and you talk to the fellas
a certain way.
-Okay.
-And so, when I get on TV,
I'm projecting.
I got to make sure.
If I'm not passionate
about what I'm talking about,
why should you be passionate
about listening to me?
So I got to do that.
But!
[ Laughter ]
When the ladies are
on the air with me,
[ Softer ]
I have to change my tone
[ Laughter ]
and modify my delivery
just a little bit, you know?
That's right.
You got to, you know,
[ The Roots playing
sultry funk ]
the Barry White,
Teddy Pendergrass,
the Isley Brothers.
See, I'm from that school.
I'm from that school.
Roots! I'm from that school!
-That's okay. Yeah, yeah, yeah.
-You understand?
-Yeah, yeah, yeah.
-I mean, you know, these young
whippersnappers today,
nah, that's not my style.
-No.
-And that's how you get
"First Take," right?
And then it goes
to "Stephen A's World."
-Yeah. Well, "Stephen A's World"
is a little bit different.
It's on ESPN+ I executive
produce that with ESPN.
I could do what I want to do
there because I'm the boss.
Now, they say I could do
what I want with "First Take,"
but the ladies run that.
-I have questions
that I want to ask you.
Tiger Woods in the Masters.
I thought it was pretty awesome
to see that guy
and he did really well.
What's your take
on Tiger Woods' comeback?
-He's won already.
He can't lose.
It doesn't matter what happens
this particular weekend.
He almost died
in a car accident.
He survived
a major car accident.
Then, they told him they thought
about amputating
a part of his leg.
Then, he survived that.
Then, they said to him,
"You may never walk
straight again.
Don't even think about
a golf career again,"
and now, he's back
at the Masters.
-Yeah.
-He's already won.
[ Cheering and applause ]
-That's exactly right.
That's why I love.
Stephen A. Smith and I
are going to play
"Wheel of Opinions"
when we come back.
Stick around.